aujourd'hui on vient se parler de dioro
gaspard l'audio avec un des spécialistes
d'audio des écouteurs dont j'aime bien
vous parlez sont ça ce sont les lg
tonnes free et là on a deux nouvelles
références à venir regarder ensemble
vous avez déjà cette boîte l'arc est
arrivé dans ces énormes boîtes parce que
chez lg les choses à moitié combien
grosse boîte deuxième grosse boîte dans
la même tranche pas toujours de grosses
boîtes ont fait ça c'est énorme on a
donc d'un côté et bien ce qu'on va
retrouver ici dans ce boîtier c'est à
dire les lg tonnes free l'été 90 t 90s
qui vont vraiment être là pour les
amoureux d'audio ce qu'ils veulent de
bonne qualité une belle qualité audio
avec un très très bon son et je vous
explique salwa quelques instants et puis
une autre référence ce sont les lg
tonnes free fit sont des écouteurs dédié
pour le sport une superbe expérience
pour tout ce qu'aime là où dort le
running le sport en salle qui ont besoin
de bouger la tête de tous les côtés et
ça ne bougera pas vous avez tout un
système d'accroché grippe un peu qui a
vraiment me retenir dans vos oreilles
bref on a deux écouteurs de nouveaux
écouteurs dans la famille de l jetten
free on va donc regarder s'ils sont
intéressants s'ils sont faits pour vous
qu'est-ce qu'il vous apporte et bien sûr
lequel il faut venir porter votre choix
et je vous le dis dès maintenant si elle
ces deux produits qui vous intéressent
tous mais le lien en bas dans la
description
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalisé
en partenariat avec lg lg m'a dit tiens
monsieur heureux est ce que tu voudrais
présenter nos nouveaux écouteurs corde
il a écouté oui parce que par le passé
on l'a fait plusieurs fois et j'aime
bien ces écouteurs ça me bien la passion
mon psy bosque j'aime bien la qualité
moi j'utilise personnellement lorsque je
vais en salle de sport des écouteurs de
lg détonne free d'une génération
précédente je passe donc dès aujourd'hui
sur la nouvelle génération que vous
allez voir qui est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup davantage allez on y
va on commence tout de suite par
regarder la boîte alors l'album vous
allez voir c'est marrant parce qu'ils
ont vraiment fait un emballage carton
que je trouve très bien très honnêtement
donc vous venez d'ouvrir c'est très
simple coutteure que si tu es là en
dessous vous avez les accessoires pas
plus pas moi c'est très simple alors on
va tout de suite commencer par regarder
justement par layton frites et 90 à
l'intérieur vous allez plusieurs
accessoires à commencer par différentes
tailles d'embouts vous êtes me retrouver
ici pour vos écouteurs des embouts en
silicone vous avez en tout cas taillé
une taille médium qui est équipé
directement dessus vous avoir une taille
un peu plus là je me taille un peu plus
petit afin que tout le monde puisse le
mettre dans ses oreilles ça c'est le
premier truc deuxième point et vous faut
un petit col rond de recharge en usb
c'est pour mettre du côté du boîtier qui
lui est béat de l'autre côté donc sans
réussir à très très bien et puis dernier
tout cas c'est vachement bien c'est ce
qu'on appellera le plug and wireless
l'idée c'est quoi c'est que vous allez
venir brancher sa directement au dos de
votre boîtier et là vous venez vous
brancher avec une prise jack 3.5 c'est
du stéréo vous le retrouvez la garder
voyez alors bon si vous n'êtes pas collé
sur l'audio face à un signal stéréo qui
va venir rentré directement par deux
prises jack pour ensuite arriver dans
vos écouteurs c'est quoi l'idée derrière
c'est par exemple j'en sais rien moi
vous jouez à une console et vous voulez
vous brancher directement dans votre
console et profiter d'une expérience son
fils et bien vous pouvez de la même
manière sur une télé de la même manière
dans un avion vous prenez vous brancher
directement dans l'avion et vous avez
des écouteurs sans fil vous êtes
tranquilles dans l'avion peut venir vous
bougez directement comme ça sans avant
deux fils qui pendouillent lorsque vous
êtes en salle de sport par exemple avec
cela bien vous avez exactement le même
système vous venez vous brancher
directement derrière et vous le relier à
une machine comme ça vous avez votre
expérience son fils ait pour autant vous
avez votre boîtier branché donc ça c'est
super intéressant il ya plein de gros
bénéfices derrière là par exemple
regardez je vous parle du plug and
wireless j'ai ma nintendo switch qui est
branché directement par le cab et six
sur la prise directe orissa situe juste
là et je suis relié directement mes
écouteurs et là lorsque je joue eh bien
voyez hop j'ai leçon j'entends tout
alors je peux me remontent elles sont là
hop là je suis déjà au tac aux moulins
et lui il voit bien que je suis branché
avec la prise jack et l'âge et le son
directement dans mes écouteurs donc ça
c'est quand même vachement bien et c'est
très cool et je vous dis ne faites plus
il ya beaucoup d'usagers ici que ce soit
pour du gaming que ce soit pour du sport
pour du divertissement c'est une
innovation que je trouve super
intéressant c'est très bien d'être venu
rajouter ici directement dans la boîte
de vos écouteurs parlons de clg todd
frites et 90 on va retrouver un plat des
petits écouteurs à l'intérieur alors le
truc est vachement déjà intéressant et
j'aime beaucoup ici puis j'aimais déjà
beaucoup avant chez lg c'est la tenue
vous prenez vos écouteurs regardez vous
prenez vous les posez juste comme ça et
vous fait un petit tour paf il est posé
il est fixé et ça ne bouge pas la même
manière ici l année je le prends je mets
comme ça hop je fais un petit tour ils
sont positionnés comme ça et ça ne bouge
absolument pas dans l'oreille donc on a
une très très très bonne tenue en plus
d'avoir une très très bonne tenue ou
vous avez un truc à dire c'est que vous
avez une réduction de bruit pas si c'est
là que ça vient vous boucher les
oreilles et comme ils viennent très bien
se positionner dans vos oreilles eh bien
on entend assez peu tout le bruit
environnant tout le bruit extérieur ça
c'est une réduction de bruit passif dire
que c'est une réduction bruits
mécaniques qui vient juste vous boucher
les oreilles et qui déjà est bien fait
donc là on arrive choses c'est à dire
très bien en plus on a un super confort
on les sent quasiment pas dans les
oreilles et puis en plus ça ne bouge pas
alors on va pas chipoter on passe jeter
partout on n'est pas dans un festival de
métal mais ça ça ne bouge pas donc ça
c'est très très chouette c'est ce qu'on
appellera la performance fit
c'est-à-dire un confort qui a été
améliorée par rapport aux générations
précédentes et en plus c'est un autre
truc et je vous le montrer dans quelques
instants quand on va aller faire le tour
de l'application ils vont pouvoir vous
dire si vos écouteurs sont bien ajustés
à votre oreille ou pas et permet de
vérifier en fête et notamment justement
le fait que vous ayez choisi une tailles
d'embouts en silicone qui vraiment
adapté à la forme de vos oreilles autre
point qui a été améliorée ça je vous
l'avais déjà montré sur les générations
précédentes c'est qu'on va retrouver ce
qu'on appellerait à l'uv enano alors lui
venons nous regardez c'est écrit ici et
noir sur blanc lui veine annocé quoi eh
bien c'est de la lumière ultraviolette
vous allez pouvoir retrouver lorsque
vous allez fermer votre boîtier et
lorsqu'il est en charge la vie en baisse
jusqu'à 99 9% de certaines bactéries
notamment escherichia coli et le
staphylocoque doré et puis maintenant
comme ils ont augmenté la taille on va
pouvoir venir retrouver juste à
l'intérieur ici ça permet d'envoyer plus
de lui ça va venir nettoyer également
l'embout en silicone donc cent en termes
d'hygiène c'est quand même vachement
cool vous venez donc les reposer à
l'intérieur et dès lors qu'ils sont
branchés sur le secteur vous les prenez
vous les posez branche est vraiment
branché et là vous avez dix minutes
pendant dix minutes ça venir nettoyer
vos hambourg grâce à la lumière
ultraviolette et du fait qu'on en zone
élargie et bien dans les toits plus donc
ça c'est pareil c'est une belle
amélioration au rien toi qu'ils ont
rajouté cette année qu'on n'avait pas
les années précédentes c'est qu'on va
voir le dolby et noces avec le head
tracking latex en anglais ouais ça fait
quoi en fait vous permet d'avoir un
suivi de votre tête lorsque vous écoutez
de la musique allez on va se dire qu'en
face de moi j'ai ma source sonore vous
êtes ma source sonore et bien je prends
mes écouteurs qui les positionne dans
des oreilles comme ça et il se passe
quoi eh bien lorsque s'activent la
technologie dolby aide toi king et bien
je veux garder mon sont là ça c'est
vachement bien lorsque vous regardez un
film une série potes sont nés ici hop
vous tournez la tête et vous avez
toujours le son là alors il ya un truc
que j'aime bien parce que je retrouve
pas forcément ailleurs avec des
technologies équivalentes est bien c'est
que je trouve qu'ici pour une fois on
peut l'utiliser sur de la musique
souvent sur de la musique sacrée un tout
trop spatialisé ça éloigne de la musique
et gêne pas des masses et je trouve que
là c'est pas mal alors si vous voulez
une expérience avec un son très proche a
coûté stéréoscopique vous restez sur un
d'expérience plus normal et vous allez
voir qu'on a quand même pas mal de
possibilités dans l'application au
niveau de l'équateur pour ni en modules
et tout ça mais si vous voulez comme si
on jetait pas la réverbération d'un peu
plus d espace un peu plus de volume et
de prévenir le m ça fera exactement la
même chose ça vous qu'un drame sont là
donc si vous tournez la tête leçon va
être plus là ou plus cela dans une
oreille ou plus dans l'autre mais c'est
un truc qui peut être assez rigolo et je
trouve qu'ici qui vraiment bien réussi
ça c'est une nouveauté on n'avait pas
dans la génération précédente donc là
dessus aussi je trouve qu'elle gère
plutôt bien bossé c'est du dolby et
phreaking pour tous les usages autre
nouveauté et pas des moindres sont les
haut parleurs cette fois ci les haut
parleurs et sont faits en graphène alors
je vais pas tout vous ouvrirez vous le
décortiqué pour vous le voyez mais le
graphène ça apporte quoi apporter une
propriété de légèreté c'est un matériau
qui est un peu plus léger qui permettra
d'améliorer la performance du son et en
plus ici ou là des haut parleurs qui
sont 89% plus grand que la génération
précédente plus grand que sur les fp 9
on passe de 8 mm 11 mm vous permettra
notamment d'avoir des basses plus
puissante saronni savoure sans voix et
ça marche et puis là on retrouve
toujours le partenariat avec méridian
méridian meridian je dirais méridian qui
est le spécialiste
nick de l'audio qui apporte plein de
technologies qui permettent d'améliorer
significativement l'expérience employé
demain christine noir sur blanc gens
sont fiers et ils ont raison parce que
ça marche vraiment bien vous avez
notamment la technologie iphone space
processing autre point me direz-vous qui
est extrêmement important et je vendais
paraît tout à l'heure au début c'est ce
qu'on appellera là elle celle active
noise cancelling c'est la réduction de
bruit active vous le disais lorsque vous
les mettez dans vos oreilles bush déjà
les oreilles c'est la réduction de bruit
passive et ensuite vous avez toute
l'électronique qui va venir travailler
pour apporter une réduction bruit active
ça marche comment faites vous avez des
micros à l'extérieur micro à l'intérieur
qui vont venir analyser le son qui
arrive dans vos oreilles leçon à
l'intérieur de vos oreilles qui va venir
l'annuler par un petit jeu de passe
passe magique c'est l'électronique ça
marche comme ça et comme ça vous
profitez d'un son sans bruit sans
nuisances extérieures et là ils sont
vraiment améliorer l'activité consulting
adaptatif avec notamment une structure
qui est un peu différente avec une
optimisation de la réduction bruit
active en temps réel avec un algorithme
à double étage pas s ils ont optimisé un
peu la sauce en interne pour vous
permettre d'avoir une meilleure
réduction collective une meilleure
expérience que vous allez venir écouter
du son de la musique des films vous
balader ou même juste moi je le fais
souvent garder vos écouteurs avec la
réduction collective pour venir vous
couper du bruit extérieur sans pour
autant écouter de la musique d'ailleurs
dit moi si vous faites la même chose que
moi juste en main dans les commentaires
et puisque je vous parle du son ils se
retrouvent également le snapdragon sand
alors le snapdragon centre c'est quoi
une technologie de qualcomm qui vous
apporte ici un sont 24 bits 96 kg et une
meilleure expérience plus d'informations
dans votre signal pour avoir un son
beaucoup plus riche au niveau des appels
ils sont aussi venus améliorer la sauce
avec un capteur de conduction osseuse en
plus des micros pour avoir des
communications plus clair et un son de
meilleure qualité leur nos appels
téléphoniques l'autonomie aussi a été
améliorée on va jusqu'à 9 heures au
niveau de chaque écouteur et jusqu'à 20h
au niveau du boîtier avec la réduction
brute active coupé on peut donc aller
jusqu'à un total de 29 heures jusqu'à
maintenant heures tout en sachant qu'ici
vous avez un voyant de charge qui est
située à regarder juste là lorsque vous
venez vous le branchez vous verrez si
vous êtes chargé en cours de charge
aussi vous commencez à le charger
l'application qui est aussi plutôt bien
fichu regardez vous arrivez directement
vous avez votre équaliseur alors vous
avez choix entre immersif naturel qui
vous explique un petit peu seul à
pouvoir faire le bass boost émis par
défaut le tribal ou le 3 décembre stage
qui est aussi pas mal du tout donne un
côté un peu plus live lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique live ou même pas
forcément de la musique live ça apporte
un peu plus de clarté un peu plus d
espace je trouve ça c'est bien alors moi
ce que je vous conseille c'est j'aime
bien l'hymne r'cif j'aime bien le bass
boost le naturel je trouve un peu trop
flat c'est bien de venir rajouter un peu
plus devenir flatte un peu l'histoire
puis vous avez juste en dessous le
fameux head tracking de dolby ici donc
ça c'est plutôt bien parce que lorsque
vous le mettez bien vers suis vraiment
le mouvement de la tête voyez le son
reste par là donc ça dépend ce que vous
voulez en faire si vous aimez ça ou pas
déjà si vous voulez un slide une
expérience live une très bonne qualité
pour aller sur le 3d sound style c'est
vraiment pas mal fichu honnêtement et
puis si vous voulez vraiment une
expérience où le son reste là comme si
vous regardiez un concert et bien vous
activez le head tracking à vous de voir
si maintenant vous voulez vraiment venir
paramétrer votre équaliseur comme vous
le souhaitez vous avez deux custom que
vous donniez régler comme vous voulez ça
sort ça aussi vachement cool parce qu'on
n'a pas tous la même oreille on n'aime
pas tous écouter la musique de l'âme est
malien et puis ça va dépendre un petit
peu du style de musique qu'on vient
écouter on vous avez ici aux bandes de
fréquences porter le 64ème jusqu'à huit
kilos vous venez régler vos un frère il
parlait mandin fera très honnêtement ici
mais je pars avec un peu plus de grado
première règle est un peu vos graves aux
aigus pour ajouter de la clarté pas de
la clarté peut customiser la
customisation ça très très cool et puis
ensuite vous avez les paramètres du
contrôle de son ambiant et de l'activé
noise cancelling c'est la réduction de
bruit active vous choisit de la laisser
activer la réduction de bruit vous
voulez mettre aussi le son ambiant pour
venir amplifier le son extérieur là vous
avez deux façons de faire soit un mode
d'écouté qui lui permettra d'entendre le
son lorsque vous venez vous balader en
gros ça vous permet d'être alerté s'il
ya une voiture vous dans la rue vous
balader de ce qui peut se passe autour
de vous ça vous évite d'être trop en
faire mais parce que savoir quand même
vachement bien cette réduction de bruit
active qui vous avez un mode
conversation qui vous permet entendre
plus clairement la voie des personnes en
face de vous fabien favorise un petit
peu les fréquences médium et qui vous
avez celui du milieu qui vient couper
alors la trad est pas terrible il
appelle ça 2 donc je pense qu'il
faudrait revoir un peu faire une petite
mise à jour dans l'application bon on
vient tous coupés l'électronique si vous
voulez profiter d'une expérience en
électronique vous mettez 5 vous êtes
pena rationnellement je voulais c'est la
réduction bruit active active et vous
avez un lab avec des choses qui sont en
train de développer notamment le fait
d'avoir lu v nano et bien vous pouvez
venir le lait s'est activé à venir
pomper je pense un peu plus de batterie
ici pas nécessairement besoin à mon avis
un mode jeu également qui va venir
réduire la latence lorsque vous jouez à
des jeux vous voulez que ça soit un peu
plus peinard depuis un mois que
j'attends le match autant est assez
marrant vous prenez vos deux écouteurs
vous activez le mode chuchotant que vous
prenez votre hôte écouteurs
c'est permet de vraiment devenir capter
le son de voix pour qu'on vous entende
bien lorsque vous venez chuchoter bon si
vous voulez pas être trop entendu parler
personnes autour de vous mais que la
personne dans conversations vous
entendent bien il ya le mode chuchotant
qui est assez marrant personnalisation
du pavé tactile pareil alors là pour me
régler vous appuyez une fois deux fois
trois fois morceaux suivants morceaux
précédents diminuer le volume augmenter
le volume bon c'est assez bien fichu et
on a la main ici dans l'application et
là vous venez vraiment voir si hop là
regardez vos écouteurs sont bien réglés
à la bonne taille alors là je les mets
directement dans les oreilles j'appuie
sur démarrer ça va me faire le test je
ne bouge pas ou demande de ne pas parler
sauf quand même une autre vidéo dont il
faut se parle un peu quand même l'ag de
la musique
pin up la finito l'escargot bien voyez
les deux sont très bien ajustés donc ça
c'est très très cool terminé donc ça à
moi vous savez directement si vous avez
les bons en boule bon truc s'ils sont
bien positionnés ou pas ça va venir vous
aider mise à jour logicielle bien
évidemment puis un guide utilisateur qui
vous file un coup de main pour devenir
active est également le multipoint et le
multi perrine ce permettra de se
connecter à plusieurs appareils jusqu'à
5 appareils en même temps alors vous
allez sur l'un sur l'autre en fonction
d'eux si on vous appelle pas vous pouvez
récupérer l'appel à leur bref c'est très
pratique lecture automatique ou pas
grâce au petit port qui va détecter la
grâce aux petits capteurs qui va venir
détecter si votre écouteurs et porter
oui ou non trouvé vos écouteurs si vous
avez perdu ça va émettre un son sans
émettre un bip ans après vous avez aussi
le triage en bref je vous passe un peu
l'histoire mais l'application les
vachement complète vous avez plein de
trucs de tous les côtés donc tout ça
très très cool et puis cette application
il va gérer différents écouteurs quand
je vais donc aussi bien avoir vos tonnes
frites et 90 que vos autres écouteurs
qui sont dédiés au sport n'envoyez ya
quoi faire et en plus de ça ils sont
venus améliorer le jumelage qui a encore
plus facile vous prenez vous ouvrez vous
connecter au bluetooth ça marche
directement vous connecter c'est facile
et ça c'est bien tout en sachant qu'ici
en plus d une certification ipx4 sûr
cela qui permettra d'être résistant aux
gouttelettes et à la sueur vous avez le
google face tu perds et le microsoft
souhaite père pour se connecter
facilement aussi bien sur un pc que sur
un téléphone et plus trucs intéressants
avec android et vous pouvez sur votre
ordinateur est pas vous avez un coup de
fil vous souhaitez sur le téléphone vous
repassez son ordinateur derrière y'a que
des bénéfices là dedans donc là on est
vraiment sur les écouteurs qui sont plus
des 10 super qualité audio très bonne
expérience pour les audiophiles si
maintenant vous êtes audiophiles et vous
faites du sport et bien vous allez là
dessus alors ses nouveaux écouteurs ils
sont vachement intéressant également
envoyé que le boîtier déjà il ya une
forme qui est un peu différente plus
allongée très ergonomique avec un côté
un peu gris poté grippe qu'on a peint
sur les autres là on a vraiment un côté
grippe on les sent bien dans la main à
l'intérieur vous allez avoir un truc qui
est un peu différent au delà de la
couleur attention c'est que vous avez
cette petite partie cette petite ailette
qui va vraiment venir se poser davantage
dans votre oreille pour venir apporter
un peu plus de tenue déjà cela comme ils
sont là il ya de la taille du fumet la
donne alors c'est une nouvelle techno
qu'on appellera le strive grippe alors
regarde mais bon je montre comment ça se
positionne je viens de prendre dans mon
oreille je vis là et je reviens
légèrement en arrière pour que toute
cette partie là voyez viennent vraiment
se positionner à l'intérieur de mon
oreille ce qui fait que l'âge d'une
super tenue en faire pareil de l'autre
côté regardez je le prends je viens je
tourne à l'intérieur je tourne comme çà
et là la voyez je suis bien positionner
directement à l'intérieur de mon oreille
je veux bien admettre comme ça donc ça
c'est vachement cool parce que au moins
j'ai une tenue qui ont pu se renforcer
et là je peux aller courir sur un tapis
je peux être bang et je peux me balader
je peux faire du rhony je peux faire des
haltères les haltères c'est plus les
bras que la tête mais voyez si je suis
sur un tapis de course et je suis sur un
vélo si je fais du vélo elliptique si je
fais du rameur je suis peinard ça va pas
bouger donc ça c'est très très court
pour avoir c'est vraiment très très très
bonne tenue voyez tout est fait comme ça
ça ça vient dans votre oreille et
ensuite à cette partie là qui vient
rajouter vraiment tarderont fort belle
tenue donc là vous êtes vraiment
tranquille et peña en plus à
l'ajustement été étudiés testé par l'un
des plus grands organismes de recherche
européen c'est le sintef
sinterklaas72 écoutant la ici on a une
certification ip67 résistant à l'eau
alors on va pas venir aller dans une
piscine on va pas venir ce bélier avec
ses pales but mais si par contre vous
transpirez beaucoup s'il se met à
pleuvoir si elle l'eau qui tombe dessus
vous n'avez aucun problème en parle bien
ici de 12 bien évidemment et si vous
voulez venir de la même manière à les
rincer à l'eau douce passer un coup
dessus et puis vous vous lavez séchez
directement vous n'aurez pas de problème
parce qu'ils sont certifiés justement
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
résistant jusqu'à un mètre pendant 30
minutes maximum donc si vous avez un
sport nautique légers comme le paddle le
kayak ou alors même le pédalo très léger
pouvait les prendre très facilement rec
en pédalo avec vos écouteurs il ya que
là vous allez être bien avec toi vous la
péter sur la plage par contre attention
si vous faites ça vous pensez vraiment à
venir bien vous sécher les mains avant
de venir à manipuler le boiter parce que
lui certifié du tout comme sur l'autre
produit bien vous avez lu vénaux qui a
été amélioré et élargit profiter
toujours 2 l'application derrière vous
avez toujours l'appairage facile vous
avez toujours le multipoint et
l'appairage multiples qui a été
améliorée comme dans l'autre appareil de
la commande vocale une communication
claire grâce à la détection de la voie à
une réduction de bruit actif qui a été
amélioré également et puis un son clair
avec meridian méridian le spécialiste
britannique également ici puisqu'on va
retrouver ici le même partenariat alors
la voyez la petite lumière mélo qui
s'allume lorsque jour la lumière bleue
ce n'est pas du tout les ultraviolets
parce que l'ultra violet est une lumière
qui est totalement invisible à l'oeil
humain donc lorsque vous l'ouvrez
ouvriers de la lumière bleue soyez
rassurés il ya absolument aucun risque
que ça ne marche uniquement boîtier
fermé et en charge ça nous lui dit vous
avez également le plug in wireless ça je
vous dis le gros gros bénéfices sur ces
écouteurs la savoir ce qu'on fait en
salle de sport voulez vous brancher sur
une machine et bien vous pouvez laisser
ça à côté avoir vos écouteurs sur un
tapis de course sur le papier les petits
regarder une sphère il y écouter
l'entraînement écouter de la musique
directement liée à votre machine très
facilement une autonomie qui était
également amélioré on va jusqu'à 10
heures par écouteurs et jusqu'à 20h au
niveau du boîtier avec la réduction
bruit actif qui est coupée donc on va
jusqu'à 30 heures maximum ici
d'expériences musicales avec une seule
charge si ces écouteurs vous intéresse
je vous mets bien évidemment les liens
juste en bas dans la description les
chutes arrêt parce qu'elles sont
vraiment intéressant d'être deux univers
réellement différent l'univers plus pour
les audiophiles avec une très belle
tenue très très beau écouteurs boîtier
un peu plus petit avec le maximum de ce
que peut vous proposer lg aussi en
termes de technologie puis pour tous les
sportifs tous ceux qui veulent s'amuser
de ceux qui veulent une meilleure tenue
et qui n'ont pas peur de croiser un
petit peu d'eau douce et bien vous avez
ces écouteurs là qui sont aussi super
bien je pense que vous en penser ce que
ça pourrait vous intéresser ce que vous
avez déjà eu vous des écouteurs de lgl
jetten free quelle que soit la référence
personnellement magasinage sont vraiment
intéressants oblige les utilisateurs
d'utiliser déjà avançant cette
génération ce que j'allais faire
notamment du sport et puis là je
continue à les trouver vraiment sexy
super intéressant donc dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez vous marrer tout ça
juste en bas en commentaire et puis
d'ici là portez vous bien caen thébaux
bien amusez vous bien de l'amour de sa
douce et mercy elle jette on va
retourner cette vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]